- So you're commentating
with Olympic figure skater, Johnny Weir
and your outfit coordination is on point.
I love y'all,
you're both there for
it so, I'm just saying.
- Really understated, right?
Very understated.
- Exactly, exactly.
Subtle.
- But we have the best time.
We like to match, we like to coordinate,
it's figure skating, we
gotta bring the sparkle,
we gotta bring the drama so
and he's my best friend
so it's double the fun.
- I love that.
That's so fun to get to
work with like a best friend
and like, just have fun
while you're working.
So you guys also find ways
to stay competitive though,
right behind the scenes?
- Yeah, it's still an athlete at heart.
We'll we have a telestrator
that's new to our booth this year.
So we'll play game on that.
(laughing)
We'll figure things out.
We also always share adjoining rooms
when we're at the Olympics.
So after the events
and when we're figuring out
our outfits for the next day
or having dinner, we get to be so close.
So it's really special.
- I love that.
- Obviously, I love what I do,
I love being part of figure skating,
but doing it with Johnny,
sitting to my best friend
it just makes it so much more fun.